this is the first kind of motion we're
focusing on which is extension one
explicitly two important ideas for you
are two important players when we have a
look at the physical world there are
lots of kinds of views that exhibit
motion or behavior that is back and
forth back and forth and the two words
depending on what object is moving back
and forth the two words we tend to use
are fluctuating or oscillating if you've
got something which is like let's say
our heartbeat fluctuates and you can see
in fact if you look at I am an educator
you can see the graph going up and down
if you've got a physical object like say
a pendulum or if you've got a physical
object like a pendulum you would say
it's oscillating back and forth between
two ends right there are lots of other
kinds of things I'm not explicitly well
you think about actual objects you can
hold so for example vibrations right so
sound for instance is a vibration that
propagates through a medium anything on
the electromagnetic spectrum right
whether it's radio waves x-ray is
visible like all of it is made up of
oscillating waves right or we talked
about objects that move up and down
because of the time tides also exist
okay all these kinds of fluctuating
oscillating phenomena they are all
governed by wave functions sine cosine
some addition of sine and cosine we're
going to focus on one subset of those
what makes simplify my Commission which
by the way I'm quite happy for you to
abbreviate as I am not to be confused
with this Sydney Morning Herald simple
harmonic motion
you are fine our fine people right in
this end you know that enough there for
SNHU no but ya know what makes simple
harmonic motion simple is that we think
about a single sine function or a single
cosine bunny okay so let's just draw one
quickly so if we have an object and
again we're still by the way remember
this is what we go through to you know
motion so this is still on a straight
line this is not moving a 2d space this
is looking at slices of time right see
you've got an origin here and then as
you go through time it comes away from
the origin come back and goes back it
goes back and forth we call that in this
case in this case the origin is the
centre of motion okay so what's the
middle point a point that it's going
fastest past we call that the center of
Russian we might label this actually
you've got
remembering that the origin on the
diagram doesn't constitute the origin
physically of what's going on right it's
just one of the instances where the
origin is everywhere along the time axis
is the physical origin that's when I
pause so you have a center of motion
right there in the middle and then ends
yeah
you have the ends of the motion right so
we call these the extremes of motion
these are the farthest plants you can
get to now a lot of this is really just
restating stuff that we knew from trig
functions like talking about periods or
frequency now this idea here of I'm
taking just a single sine function or a
single cosine function that's that make
it simple harmonic motion we're still in
a sort of kinematic sense here we're
just thinking how this object is moving
but just to say for all of you because
the curious is particularly for the
extension to suits because we're gonna
go in that direction in a minute what
makes simple harmonic motion fluctuating
I sleep like this is what we call
different color is what we call a
restoring force a restoring force so
this is from a mechanical point of view
now now if I was actually interested in
Y what forces are being exerted here Y
is the object to eat the motion that
it's doing it's a restoring force such
as Austria lasting right now just for
your last thing as I pull the part okay
as I pull these apart there's tension in
the rubber band okay
the further I pulled the more tension
there is the tension axes are restoring
force it's pulling me back towards the
centre of motion and then if my thumb
just kept on doing its thing it would go
all on the other end and then there's a
restoring force in the opposite
direction and back and forth and back
and forth so in this case the tension of
the string of the remand is the
restoring force if you would think about
a arm I was doing that a pendulum
before right so a pendulum is sweet back
there for that
and for what is it what's the restoring
force that makes it once it gets to an
end that makes it come back why does it
do that it's grabbing right because it
goes too high then you're like oh I've
run out of kinetic energy right so it's
all it's a potential energy now and you
just come back down your swing past and
then you come back gravity pulls you
back - okay so that's what a restoring
force is it's bringing you back towards
the center okay now I mentioned this
right at the beginning of motion the
opposite of a restoring force right the
opposite of force that sends you back
the direction that you came from and
then perpetuates the motion is a
resisting force a restoring force
continues the motion they keep going
keep going keep going
a resisting force does exactly the
opposite and say whatever you're doing I
want you to stop doing that right so for
instance movement through a viscous
medium okay if we are moving through air
or water that air all those air
particles that you're running into or
the water you're trying to swim through
it's resisting you it's trying to stop
the motion that you're exerting right in
the case of the pendulum gravity was a
restoring force it made the motion
continue okay but just as easily gravity
can be a resisting force can someone
give me an example of when gravity is
going to resist the motion that you're
doing yeah yeah any projectiles
that's upward right gets resisted any
object that is trying to escape gravity
right on any object that's moving
upwards whether it's a direct projectile
or a self propelled object the force is
resisting its motion okay so that's why
it stops the motion versus a restorative
force okay anyway that's a bit of a arm
and extension to mechanics Fortner